all right thank you everyone it's really
great to be here over the break I was
also looking at a little bit my history
of PI data because it's a really
meaningful moment for me to be standing
here giving hopefully a little bit back
because I I actually I I looked what the
first meetup that I went to from PI data
was in 2014 at pivotal labs law over
four years ago I've been to twenty at
least according to meetup signups which
I'm not sure if that's a good always a
good estimate but about that so it's
it's really meaningful moment to be here
now after like this meetup has taught me
so much because I remember being here I
was at my first data science job proper
data science job I guess starry-eyed you
know like thinking about unit tests like
why would I write more code that tests
my code
well those were the days but anyway so
it's really great to be here I also was
surprised to find out that my previous
speaker was also check and I met a
mother check in the audience and
randomly so this meetup is becoming a
real checkbook exercise if you will
anyway so okay so before we get into the
nature of the talk this just disappeared
I just want to have like a little bit of
sense of who here has heard of a gam a
generative adverse feel network perfect
who knows what again is and could like
kind of describe it raise your hand all
right yeah that's good that's good
who here has ever implemented one or
played around with one fewer yeah okay
that then maybe this is a good segue I
mean this is a specific paper it's one
of the the like cutting-edge ones has
been presented at I see LR 2018 in
Vancouver I believe or somewhere in
Canada in April and May so it's this is
really cutting-edge stuff because it's
just been presented so by myself just
very quickly I mean I kind of see myself
like as an like educator I kind of like
the the sort of explaining about concept
like really really simply so
I teach it a couple of universities and
obviously not as a professor but like
it's just part of their like continuing
education that sort of thing so I really
like doing this kind of stuff hopefully
like usually in a much smaller setting
anyway so that's just briefly my me I
currently I'm working as like a 90 day 2
scientist at Madonna so let's get to it
what is generative modeling and why is
that an interesting problem so basically
I think everyone here is familiar with
some sense of sort of discriminative
like machine learning that's typically
how we all get introduced to to any kind
of machine modeling problem we have some
sort of function that or some sort of
model that we're trying to basically
estimate its parameters to to get out a
prediction right there typically is some
sort of classification or something like
that
now generative modeling obviously falls
into one typically falls into the
unsupervised world so no longer are you
in a space where you have a clear set of
labels but you're instead trying to
learn this like some learner Bowl
function generator right that is what
we're trying to accomplish with a lot of
the machine learning machine learning
generative models which obviously there
are also analytical ones but this is
these are the ones that we're going to
be focusing on today so ultimately it's
all sort of derived for some maximum
likelihood you're trying to basically
maximize the likelihood of your data
being real right so on a sort of
conceptual level what we're trying to
get to is okay so there's some data and
we're trying to create a set of creating
some sort of model that that when you
plot running through that this magical
function that we are not like looking
into too much for now just generates out
something that looks real right like
that's the broad objective and obviously
there's like difference perhaps like
explicit models which are like pixel RN
and and and all sorts of things
variational autoencoders are in fact
what you see here so this is the they're
kind of like some way of generating em
this which is really like the hello
world bright like the handwritten digits
and slowly getting better and better
results right so I think that's kind of
what the machine learning part of of
generative modeling is really about
right like we're trying to improve the
way our examples look it
actively right so the explicit is
probably closest to what most people
know right so you have some sort of lost
function and you're trying to really
optimize that so via actually has like
an explicit loss function opposite of
that is as the implicit part right so in
this case like something like a
generative adversarial Network has very
there is no clear and like there's no
clear measurement by which we can say
yeah this is a good gun and and actually
that's some of the one of the larger
problems in generative adversarial
modeling is that we have there's just
starting to be metrics of how good of a
visual quality of a sample that is so by
the way I just had a question in the
break like Ganz can be used for lots of
things I'll just talk about imagery
because that's the by far the most
mature field within guns right so
obviously how do we even estimate this
like maximum likelihood problem that's
like the function ultimately is pretty
complicated right so so how do we even
go about that so we can use the
generative at a cell network so I think
this is like the first time we'll kind
of go over it and and we'll look at it
in a couple of different ways because
the concept I think most people
encounter it starts to be it can be a
little bit unintuitive so basically we
always start out can you see my mouse
okay cool so obviously we have to start
with some training data we don't need
labels where announcer provides world so
that's all good right and and then and I
think there's the the concept is there's
basically three parts right so networks
so that's the third word so that there's
two obviously so there's the generator
and the discriminator they're
adversarial so they're competing we'll
talk about that and their generative
which we already talked about right so
the discriminator itself is is basically
just a supervised algorithm right it has
to make a binary prediction right real
or not real fake or real right so so
it's just 1 or 0 so that's pretty simple
right we have to we are kind of
understand this from the supervised
world right like this is just a more
complicated version of of some sort of
classification this is
just a part of a classification wall
right within a more complicated setup so
the generator is typically of more
interest and is typically also more
complicated so we understand that like
we kind of have some like seed like
random seed so that's basically what
this latent sample is so you sample from
some random distribution you run it
through some magical function and that
gives you something that looks real or
not like it just kind of generates
something in the first instance all
right like you just initialized the
model it's not very clear that it should
be any good right at this stage so
there's this this process that the
discriminator starts to do so the
discriminator is basically sometimes
seeing the real data and sometimes
seeing the fake data and because of that
it gets better at recognizing what's
looks real and what looks fake so
obviously it kind of starts to look at
okay so this starts to have some
cohesion
whereas this generated example does not
have really like any sort of consistency
it's just a bunch of random points right
so it basically generates a feedback
that can that then gets back propagated
through the generator so yeah so
basically itself like has as its own
stochastic gradient so obviously updates
so doing this loop it gets better over
time and then you have the generator
which also has another separate loss
that's independent of the discriminator
and both are basically trying to beat
each other because they're they're
competitive at some way so I know that
it's probably confusing so let's go
through this in a different way so what
does that mean so generator basically
takes in a vector more random numbers
Rumble num numbers and then basically
tries to create examples there as
convincing as possible right so you're
trying to basically minimize your loss
by convincing the discriminator that
your examples are real right and then
obviously that in and the the byproduct
of that is that the the data that you
generate are indistinguishable from data
set right so we're still in unsupervised
world
the generator actually never ever if you
look at this gets to see what the real
data looks like it only what it gets is
the feedback from the discriminator and
then the discriminator basically gets
the two types data either the fake one
or the real one and the the objective is
basically to tell which is which and
then that's what we're trying to
generate so a helpful analogy to think
about this is kind of like you have a
painter who's trying to basically create
like a lost piece of da Vinci or
something right and and you have an art
critic who's trying to distinguish what
work should go into an art gallery right
so when you take this sort of painter
amateur painter who's like the generator
they're trying to obviously they're
first gonna carve sent something and
they're not very good so the picture is
like all over the place right the next
step that they do a they submit it to
the gallery and the discriminator the
art critic says no this is not any good
right so that way the the painter gets
to learn right the amateur painter gets
to learn okay I need to improve maybe
they get some feedback on like what are
the broad high level problems that they
need to address in their next work right
and maybe that word gets better and so
it passes the art critic next time
around so hopefully by this point it's
starting to make a little bit more sense
and basically like it kind of creates
this competitive dynamic right like
they're trying to fool each other right
like the same way an art critic might
try the best you know for some ego
reasons or whatever like trying to feed
this amateur painter who's trying to
then deceive him because they're you
know they're trying to make money or
something okay so there will be some
math so don't if you were terrified like
I was from the last talk don't be
because hope like I'll explain this in a
lot more detail so basically this is
their to loss functions right we already
talked about this they're competitive so
there's the discriminator which you know
when you look at it okay this is kind of
confusing but there's some log so you
can forget about those for the time
being there's some house whatever but
basically it's expectation okay so that
just means like you know as we kind of
go towards the limit and then
but what's really important is it's this
bit right like you can kind of make out
like almost a traditional binary
classification lost function in here
right so this is the discriminator and
what we're saying is okay so we're
basically trying to you know optimize
for this value so that we're so that
we're accepting you know we're
minimizing this this quantity where
we're accepting the real examples and
we're rejecting the examples which were
generated by the generator right so so
this is just the generated part right so
G of Z Z is the latent space vector
right so we take some number that gives
us the GFC gives us the exact actual
example which we then run through the
discriminator and hopefully you know
this you're good discriminator would
tell that this quantity should be equal
oh and this question should be quite
high depending on which depending on
whether the sample is real or fake and
then the in the original formulation
it's been formulated as a game
theoretical framework so there's
basically it's a min/max game so I don't
know if for those of you who are
familiar with game theory it's basically
like you're trying to basically like
play like a complication of prisoner's
dilemma right where you're trying to
basically best the other player in this
sort of competitive game without sort of
yeah and thereby improving at the actual
generative process which is a side
product but that's actually what we want
right so in this case the generator in
the original formulation is literally
just negative of the discriminator so
then that formulation has a number of
problems I won't really get into them
but basically it's about like saturating
gradients and and and generally being
very difficult to to work with that type
of gap but it is well theoretically
founded so what people what even in
Goodfellow the author of Gans in the
original work came up with sorry is this
non-saturated objective so this is the
one that
will actually use most of the time I
mean there's actually an even better
improved version called assertion gap
but let's not get into that so basically
in this case you can kind of see again
there's a degree of similarity but
they're now independent of each other so
it's more sort of tractable now you have
this concept of you know like I think
the old the key takeaway from the side
I'm also kind of running out of time
already is
we need to these these two things look
pretty similar right so just the second
part and this so so that's basically the
key insight right like they're still
kind of directionally so these two it's
still directionally equivalent but
they're no longer they're no longer sort
of just you know directly dependent on
each other but it preserves the
competitive dynamic so the training is a
trick tip so I think one thing that
maybe trips people over sometimes is
like okay but why does the how does the
discriminator know anything how does the
generator know anything so obviously you
have to think about that this gets
better over time
so both the discriminator and the
generator have a sort of you know
training loop and and obviously both of
them start up being relatively bad and
the early samples you'll get from the
generator will be bad and the early
decisions that you get from the
discriminator will be bad so it's
basically about like creating this loop
through which that kind of one by one
sort of both of them get better over
time right so hopefully that this kind
of makes it some nonsense at this point
yeah yeah okay good
right so why is this an interesting
problem right so largely unsolved
there's one bunch of AI celebs that are
saying like look unsupervised learning
is the future I think you can kind of
start to see why when you look at how
difficult it is to get labels and in
like most of our day to day jobs like we
run across that problem in there's not
enough data or just not enough high
enough quality there's all sorts of
problems right and typically like this
is like the the pictures that you can
see here are like generated by
variational auto encoder which I think
it's like in many ways the closest
predecessor to Ganz because
kind of generative models and they're
very blurry those pictures around the
edges especially there's a reason for
that
but won't get into that but you know
they're not very high quality they're
not that great but they're like they
kind of started the generative modeling
paradigm
they're basically unsupervised as well
so and there's kind of lots of
interesting applications that you can do
in and we might get into that towards
the end but okay so what do games but
backward games what can they do actually
so well you can see here this is
actually the work from the paper these
are all generated synthetic examples
1024 by 1024 full HD images that are
completely synthetic right and you can
actually if you go to tensorflow hub you
can download a pre train model bit
smaller than this I think the but
largest they have is 128 by 128 and you
can run it on your local machine right
and that's incredible that you can
actually generate and examples of this
quality with just basically three and a
half years after the technique was even
proposed right so we've beaten the state
of the art from marriage Nolen code or
auto-encoders and here we are so what do
the what have the researchers at Nvidia
by the way their name the name of the
lead-off there is chaos which i think is
spelled differently but i think like
that's how you know you're like destined
for deep learning right anyway so what
is a guy doing right like okay like we
have all these late in space and we can
like interpolate in it and then generate
all these different examples this is
also from that paper by the way what
does that mean so basically there's this
manifold assumption right like you have
the latent space and you're trying to
basically when you run that through some
generating function you're trying to
like capture some like parts of the
manifold of where the real samples live
right because that space is obviously
much higher dimensional than your
seeding vector which is typically of
like a hundred dimension like not very
much so I think this is like a very neat
way of thinking about it like and
actually these graphics are for from his
presentation as well they're all in the
references by the way so you can take a
look at them later but like you can
think about the manifold
there's like an archipelago right like
it's like a bunch of islands most of the
mass is water like generally not good
examples right like you don't want to be
there you want to optimize your
generative function so that it maps on
to the islands right like so this sparse
space that's kind of like not very
intuitively distributed in our heads
obviously so we just kind of want to
push it push it so that the examples
that the generator generates
consistently come from those islands
those good examples right they look
quite realistic like those ones rather
than the ones that kind of like look
kind of off right these are kind of like
what is that that that looks weird so so
we want to just twist that kind of that
that generating process okay so lots of
math scary so basically what they have
proposed is this progressive
progressively growing of the network so
basically what they do is they
manipulate this sort of lost space right
by changing the complexity of the two
networks so we still have our loss
function so this is actually the one of
the improved one we're staying again but
it's still the same concept right so you
can imagine your your gantt your
generate example as a surfer right and
you're trying to get push into the
island right so you have this this tool
this is the the the discriminant
discriminator has this tool of this wave
spike manipulating the lost space so
that the gener the de generators push
towards the good examples right that
push towards the the land so the idea is
obviously as we kind of manipulate this
loss that we are introducing these
penalties that kind of automatically
guide us towards what we want to do well
so I think it may be a better way of
thinking about it is okay so this is
like where we get to at the end right so
we're generating full full HD images but
actually that's still really difficult
to get to that space so what we want to
do instead is is we kind of want to like
look at much lower dimensional
representation initially to help inform
the model right so we don't start with
this really really high dimensional
manifold that we're trying to optimize
because that's confusing for the network
as well and in fact
stability is a massive problem with guns
so instead we kind of like start with
something much smaller right and then we
progressively grow it back right so we
simplified the space first push like
start pushing the surfer the good
examples towards the shore and and then
when we're more comfortable with the
training process we can introduce the
extra complexity back right so so
basically like this is kind of how we
start and then as we okay okay yeah so
and then and then you know so this is
kind of that the iterative process right
so we introduced those extra layers we
double the size so it's basically two
like convolutional and what's called
transpose convolution or d convolutional
sometimes but people don't like it once
they say they couldn't be convolutional
so say transposed anyway so but it's
basically the same process right so you
are trying to like upscale that
generates the samples from the latent
vector that's of a different
representation different dimensionality
and you're trying to increase the
complexity so that you eventually get
above both like simultaneously a very
complex models on both ends which can
generate those beautiful images right so
okay well so we're introducing these
extra layers and they're doubled the
size how do we do that that seems like
that would like introduce a shock to the
system right and you'd be right and
that's why there's another sort of neat
addition from this paper where they kind
of upscale with some sort of like like
bicubic upscaling or some simple
algorithm right and then you smoothly
interpolate between the two versions
right so you start off with with a very
you start out with just an upscaled
version of the 4x4 in the beginning
right and then you then you start to
introduce the extra layers and you start
to compose that image that the
discriminator gets to see as as more and
more to be generated by the actual
already upscale layer rather than taking
the 4x4 up scaling it with some like you
know nonparametric
algorithm and then and and then feeding
it to the generator to the discriminator
so hopefully like we're just basically
trying to avoid the shock to the system
right we're trying to smooth that out
with some like alpha that we kind of
very through the training time and as we
get more confident we kind of get rid of
that and then we move on to the next
layer right and we do sixteen by sixteen
right so variation so this is actually a
picture from another paper that came out
like three or four days ago
but basically variation is another
massive problem so I think I don't won't
go into the work that the guys have done
in here but basically but Gans suffer
from a lot is something called mode
collapse so mode collapse is where the
gaen kind of learns couple of examples
they're all very similar to each other
so we're trying to basically spread them
out and they have introduced this need
extra statistic that they into that they
give to the to the discriminator as a
helping tool I don't know I don't think
I have time to go into that but his talk
is also online you can read in the paper
so yeah so many bad standard deviation
but I just kind of want to cover like a
little bit of the context right so Gans
have had like fantastic couple years
there's now over a thousand papers I
think this graph only shows like five
hundred but depends how broadly defined
Gans because once you get into advanced
architectures to start to get a little
bit click crazy there's other
innovations that this paper introduced
and is one of the reasons why is one of
my favorites is because actually the
amount of like problems that they solve
with a lot of their techniques not
everything is the best they could be
like other people have produced like
better training mechanisms or better
metrics but like these guys have done an
absolutely phenomenal job of sort of
solving a lot of the problems that
existed in Gans at the time this was one
of this was the first Gann model to
being to made it into TF hub which is a
Google sort of repository for pre chain
models so you can go and run it in your
in
local machine it's actually just like a
couple lines of codes very simple but so
yeah so there's a lot of work that's
being done I kind of wanted to show just
a little bit of how like what is the
actually this progressive growing give
you like what are the actual effects
just for comparison right so so you can
see kind of it's it's like you can
really see how the layers are being
added and you can kind of see that it's
a lot more stable than if you just
started with the fixed resolution so you
can see that our predictions are just
intuitive understanding has kind of
matched what we observe when we look at
the actual generating process right so
that's quite exciting
which doesn't always work out that way
but you know awesome I don't think I
have time to run through the code just
wanted to like talk to these are the
references if people want to take a
picture right yeah well we can talk
about that later okay
right anyway so yeah the reference is
for sure okay cool also um as I kind of
hinted in beginning I'm writing a book
about this you can get that address if
you feel like that's too much Shelley is
also written like an amazing amazing
book and we're kind of trying to write
it so that uh me and my co-author that
it's actually like at the level we're
almost after you're finishing this book
you can pick this up if you do that
you're probably going to have to Google
a lot but it's it's like almost possible
so that's kind of how we're trying to
aim it all so we're hiring for client
facing data scientists at Madonna so
there's my email address if you want to
but yeah I think that's everything
so I think I even made it on time
[Applause]
thank you thank you bro we probably do
have time for a couple of questions
it was the Jacobi microphone nearby you
saw this action doesn't work yes hey
thanks for the talk go was curious what
the relationship between ganz and some
of like the reinforcements like actor
critic type models is right yeah that's
a great question so there have been a
couple of papers trying to connect the
two I especially like work by foul I
think who's a deep mind
I don't like know the details of that
work there's like already over a
thousand paper so I obviously don't know
all the details of all of them one thing
I'll say though is so what I've touched
on and you can kind of see it in in the
progressive gand paper but more
importantly one very popular way of
framing the gap problem is something
called the Vassar Stein gap and message
down again so they kind of borrow a lot
of the underlying maths from
reinforcement learning and actually they
kind of renamed the discriminator to be
a critic rather than discriminator so
they like they tried like unified the
terminology with that world but I think
yeah so I think foul 2016 I don't quite
remember the name but basically like
connecting actor critic methods and
gansan like that okay right so yeah I
think that's probably the best place to
start I think there have been other
examples I just I haven't had time to
read all those papers love it
one more question perhaps love it
whisper here if you will grab microphone
good button hey generating samples is
fun but most use cases they really care
about